right now we are in a recession it is
undeniable the bank of England have said
that the recession that we are entering
right now is possibly going to be the
worst darkest hardest recession that we
have seen for over 100 years yes a
century the property Market is crashing
as we speak house prices are dropping
and a lot of people in the UK are going
to be absolutely doomed unless they have
a serious plan of action of what they're
going to be doing I am not a doom and
gloom type person I am a positive glass
half full kind of guy but I would be
completely lying to you if I said that
the economy was going well if I said
that house prices were going up and if I
said that we were not in a recession we
are so in this video I'm going to talk
to you about what the heck is going on
in the economy about why the recession
is happening and about what you can do
about it now I do believe that we create
our own economy as business people but
if you're not aware of what's going on
in the economy then how on Earth can you
create and control your economy so if
you enjoy my channel and if you
appreciate the information I literally
spend hundreds of thousands of pounds
studying I spend hundreds of thousands
of pounds every year sitting with
lawyers accountants Brokers Specialists
coming up with my plans and my
strategies and I Give It Away on YouTube
for free so if you appreciate that hit
the like button drop a supportive nice
comment below and subscribe to the
channel if you're not subscribed you're
a complete jerk because go back 18
months ago when base rate was 0.1
percent
that means base rate by the way Bank of
England base rate what that means is you
need to understand this the bank when
they lend you money if you get a
mortgage for example where does the bank
get that money from they borrow it
themselves from the bank of England so
they're borrowing money from the bank of
England and then they're loaning it out
to you and to me in order to get a
mortgage to buy a house base rate is how
much the bank of England are charging
the banks to borrow money from them
that's what base rate is base rate went
down to 0.1 percent so in March
2020 it dropped to 0.1 percent right up
until
2021. so for ages base rate was so low
it had never been it hadn't been that
low in over
400 years and I was doing videos
saying base rate zero I was shouting in
the video so base trades 0.1 it's not
been this low in over 400 years buy
properties and fix your interest rate so
I was pleading I think fix your interest
rates
three percent and fix it for five years
do you remember
is what's going to be said in five six
years time now interest rates have gone
up interest rates right now if you want
to buy a house you want to buy a
property and rent it out you're gonna be
paying about seven eight percent
it's crazy
so I was saying buy houses get a
mortgage and fix your rates we are in a
massive opportunity this is a revolution
and most of you in the comments were
laughing at me was saying Samuel's
aggressive he seems desperate to try and
sell a course or something no I'm not
desperate to try and sell a course or
something I'm passionate because I could
see the opportunity and now everybody's
screwed and now fast forward now 2022 as
we enter into 2003 can't buy a house
anymore if you want to buy a house and
you're an average person you are screwed
because the average salary is two to
three grand a month
after you paid your tax
if you're on two grand a month and you
have to pay you're gonna have to pay
your National Insurance
your pens should put money into a
pension because that's the whole scheme
they want you to go down you have to pay
pay
aye tax you're gonna be left from about
1 600. well sorry
but in the last few years interest rates
have gone up but so of rents and house
prices and food and all Commodities so
if you're on take home 1 600
how are you gonna live can't screwed
because rent average rent in England is
one thousand pounds
utility bills have gone up by three
times at least
just this year
so if you were renting a house and
you're paying 600 Quid and you're paying
300 pounds a month for your bills 900
quid you're left with 700 pounds a month
on your food and stuff now your rent's
gone to a thousand pounds and your bills
that were 300 pounds are now 900 pounds
you haven't got enough money to have a
roof over your head let alone eat eating
is a luxury
and because of that there's a massive
crisis Martin Lewis even came out and
said
can't help you anymore because trying to
save money on tariffs and didn't work
if you want to buy a house now rent it
out you're screwed because number one
how are you going to save up for a
deposit on a house
because house prices are going up if you
were saving like an idiot five years ago
and you were saving 500 pound a month
and it's been five years and you finally
got 30 grand
to buy a house that ain't enough to buy
a house anymore because house prices
have doubled so now you need double the
deposit so the money that you were
saving is shrinking and because of
quantitative easing you if you don't
know what that is check it out
quantitative easing because when Banks
print money so because of quantitative
easing that 30 000 pounds not only is
not enough to buy a house but it's also
not enough to do anything because it's
much it's much smaller than it was
because money as they print more money
the money becomes worth less money
because it's like it's like anything
it's like if you've got a car and
there's only 20 cars in the world like
that car it holds its value they're
going to build or make another 100 cars
it loses its value same as money money
is becoming so worthless and my wife is
from Zimbabwe in Zimbabwe you see them
with wheelbarrows of money to buy food
the same thing is happening in the UK so
if you're in a job right now on 2 000
pounds a month saving to buy a house you
can't another reason you can't because
even if you save the money even if
you're really fortunate and you're on 10
grand a month if you save up the money
to buy a house you're gonna need about
100 Grand right now to buy a house
because the average house is 300 Grand
you're going to 25 deposit
and then you're gonna they've up stamped
you today
legal fees all right I mean just the
deposit alone is going to be what 300
Grand it's about 75 grams plus your
stamp Duty another ten push your legals
you're gonna be the best part of 100
Grand let's say you've got 100 Grand and
you buy a house and it's the 300 grand
house and you rent it out for a thousand
pounds a month you're done because your
mortgage is going to be about 225 Grand
and if you're having to pay interest of
eight percent that means for your
interest payments on the mortgage are
going to be about fifteen hundred pounds
minimum payment interest only a month
just to pay the interest
that's more than the rent
that means that you're going to be
having a house and you're going to be
losing money every month from the house
and then you're going to get taxed on
that rent too because the section 24 tax
which only came in in 2020. the game's
changed
so that's the bad news the good news is
that if you understand what's going on
in the economy and you understand what's
going to happen in the future I'll tell
you what's going to happen in the future
in my opinion because I've got a crystal
ball I can tell you exactly what's
happening and I can tell exactly what
happened my opinion is house prices are
going to drop and there's going to be a
crash and I believe they're going to go
down about 10 in 2023. I'm might be
wrong but because I don't know 100 but
they're going down and the reason I know
they're going down is because I buy a
lot of houses I'm buying houses all the
time and when I used to put an offer on
a house it's on for half a million I'll
say I'll buy it for four seven five
they'd laugh at me
it's on the 500
it was now for five
and people were gazumping each other
left right and Center it was hard
getting a good deal on the house
now now everything's different now when
you ring an estate agent about half a
million pound house and you say hey I
want to look around are they open to
office
I want to put forward enough for a 475
they'll be like oh my goodness yeah yeah
please put it Forward quick
you say 450 no problem especially if
you're a cash buyer if you're a cash
buyer you can get real juicy Bargains
right now because now it's a buyer's
market when it was a seller's market
so one of the ways that you should be
making money right now if you're just
getting started and you haven't got much
you should be thinking well I know the
Market's going to crash I know that
house prices are very likely to drop at
very least there's going to be a serious
correction because this let me explain
why okay in the past when the media have
said there's going to be a crash in the
past when the media have said the houses
are going to go down I've always
disagreed and I've always been right
but the reason I think that there will
be a serious correction maybe even a
crash
because
people can't afford to pay the interest
on the new mortgages
so because of that
it makes sense to rent a house rather
than to buy a house if you're doing buy
to let how can you afford to take on a
big Mortgage and pay eight percent
interest it doesn't stack up anymore so
because of that people have to pull out
and there's now and now people are
afraid because they know there's going
to be a crash so lots of people are
putting their houses on the market
there's more sellers than there are
buyers
so if you're a buyer you get to choose
and if you're cash and you're not going
with a mortgage so that's why I believe
that house prices are going to go down
what you could be doing is you could be
number one you could be doing deal
sourcing so you could be going out there
and you could be working on behalf of
Someone Like Me
see I'm looking for bargains right now
I'm buying aggressively so is Warren
Buffett so annoyed's Bank
so it's not a bad time to buy right now
it's just a bad time to buy at the full
market rate
but it's a great opportunity to go get a
discount to go get a bargain so what you
could be doing right now is you could be
speaking to people like Warren Buffett
maybe not Warren Buffett maybe people
like me or maybe other cash investors
and you should be saying if I can get
you a bargain if I can find you a deal
that's 25 below market value will you
pay me a finder's fee of two percent of
the purchase price
so if you find me a house that's worth
600 Grand but you managed to get it for
500 Grand I'm gonna pay you two percent
and two percent of 500 Grand is 10 grand
that's how you can make 10 grand being a
property entrepreneur
now you do that enough times
if you've got a bang my 10 grandmate 10
grand all you need to do is know how to
find deals and and get connected to
investors
how many times do you have to do that
before you've got 100 Grand to 10 times
now you can use your 100 Grand to go get
a good deal and start building your
Empire potentially that's one route okay
that's one way of being a deal saucer
how you can really thrive in this
economy in this crashing economy another
thing you could do I'm giving away all
my secrets now I hope you liked the
video at least another thing you can use
this
to buy a house or rent it out don't make
sense because the rent will hardly cover
the interest payments but
if you buy a house and you learn to rent
it out to guests instead of tenants what
that means is instead of charging a
monthly amount you charge a nightly rate
and I've got houses normal houses that
would normally rent out for a thousand
pounds a month I've got houses like that
that I've got renting out for four
thousand pound a month
quadruple because I'm renting them out
on a nightly basis on Airbnb and
booking.com I'm turning houses into many
hotels not only is it way more
profitable lucrative but I haven't got
to deal with tenants because guests
don't have rights so I don't have to
worry about all the tenant eviction bans
and and tenants rights
that's how you can make money another
thing is there's a lot when when we
enter a recession people can't afford to
go on holiday to Barbados anymore they
can't afford to go outside the country
because flights do you know that flights
have gone up by 300 percent
so I found it want to go on holiday
where they're going to go they're going
to go
in England they're going to go on a
staycation so if you've got properties
that are like Cottages or properties
that are near buzzing centers or where
tourists go you can rent them out to
Holiday makers or stay caters and you
can rent them out for five six hundred
pounds for a five day period where
normally you'd only get 500 a month so
you can really really maximize of
recessions or the times to get rich
crashes are the times to get rich if you
look at all the billionaires they got
rich and made most of their money in a
crash in a crisis never miss a good
crisis okay so that's another thing
another thing is hmos
hmos are becoming so popular if you go
to any City right now in the UK and you
go on spare room.co.uk okay you should
do this go on spare room.co.uk type in
any City Birmingham London Liverpool
Manchester Sheffield wherever
Wolverhampton you'll see that there are
dozens and dozens and dozens of people
looking to rent rooms in those cities
and there will be new adverts created
today today
why there's so many people looking for
rooms do you know that the average
amount of money that people spent to
rent a room two or three years ago was
375 pounds
now it's 650 pounds why is that why our
room rents becoming so popular everyone
said in code they were going to die hmos
are going to die and I said no they're
not you loser how can you say they're
going to die when we're entering a
recession and when you're in a recession
which means that people haven't got much
money which means that people are
wanting to downsize and instead of
living in an apartment people are going
to start looking for rooms come on and
then when bills went up everyone said
hmos aren't going to be profitable
anymore because utility bills are too
high what yes as the HMO owner you pay
for the utility bills but if HMO utility
bills go up that's a good thing because
that means everyone's balance goes up
and all the people went in apartments or
small houses that have to pay six seven
eight hundred pounds a month for a
studio flat and have to pay their bills
and their bills are going up they're
going to want to live somewhere where
their bills are included they're going
to want to live in rooms my rooms
and if everyone wants to live in my
rooms guess what's going to happen to my
rooms price is going to go up it's basic
supply and demand so I'm telling you
room rents are good another great thing
about room rents if you've got a house
you can buy in a non-article 4 area
and you turn it into a HMO which is a
house in multiple occupancy not only you
can you charge now the average room rent
is 6.50
and it was 375.
656 56 56 5650 a room but also when
Article 4 comes in you have the
automatic grandfather rights which means
that the value of the house goes up
supply and demand limited edition but on
top of that if you've got a big HMO like
six seven bedrooms and they're ensuites
did you know you can actually get a
commercial valuation on the house which
means that the value of the house can be
based off of the rents so you buy a
house cheap you rent it out room by room
and push the value up you can also do
some service accommodation and then not
only are you making super high cash flow
but you've just pushed the value of the
house up which means then you can go and
get a new mortgage and refinance and
pull all the initial money that you put
into the house pull it back out on a
buyer Photoshop Finance
I mean it's still easy to get rich it's
still very simple but now you need to be
more educated than ever another thing is
buy refurbish refinance if you're trying
to do uh flips
buy a house and flip it or buy a house
and refinance it you need to be really
careful of these things number one
make sure that you buy it cheaper than
you would over a year ago because the
end value is probably going to have gone
down so if it's only worth 100 Grand get
it for 90. then push the value up then
we Finance it bear in mind that the if
you're trying to flip it and sell it you
might struggle to sell it potentially
if you're trying to refinance it it
might get down valued so just make sure
you're buying cheap you're buying cheap
you're refurbing it and pushing the
value up I'm being super conservative on
the end value another thing is this make
sure that you if you're doing a buy
refurbatory Finance if you're going to
refinance it make sure that your rent is
going to more than cover your new
interest payments that's what you need
to learn about service accommodation HMR
I mean the thing I'm mostly I I didn't
even get started yet I'm like most
excited right now about lease optional
agreements purchase links option
agreements which is when you buy a house
you agreed to pay for it later
sometimes if you see a house and you go
I want to buy it what's it worth 200
Grand I buy it for 200 Grand but I buy
it in seven years why would someone give
you that house
without making you pay a penny and say
you can buy it in seven years and after
seven years if you don't want to buy it
you walk away but if you want to buy it
I have to sell it to you because you've
got a first charge on it you've got the
option to buy it you've got a
restriction order on the house which is
at the title Deeds so you can buy it but
you've got seven years to save up
so why is that amazing it's amazing for
a few reasons number one is because
everyone's thinking oh there's going to
be a crash yeah that probably is
but it won't last long
it's going to go down
at 10 percent
and then it's going to show up like
crazy this is I've been through two
recessions man I saw this happen in 2009
when it was a big crash look look go on
the charts go on and look at what
happened to house price in 2008 there's
a massive crash that went down and then
about two three years later
shot back up
so Now's the Time for buying and holding
and for buying good flipping and
refurbishing and refinancing if you're
buying real cheap okay
but lease option agreements right now
are so exciting because if you're buying
a house and you're saying you'll pay for
it later
who would agree to do that I'll take her
a landlord whose interest rates have
just gone up because you skipped the
Samuel Leeds 2020 class and did not fix
his interest rates for five to ten years
like I did and like my students did and
now he was paying 500 quid a month and
his rent was a thousand quid and he was
making 500 pound a month profit but now
his interest rates have gone up to 1200
quid and now he's losing 200 pound a
month and he really wants to sell but he
can't sell because no one wants to buy
because everyone knows there's a crash
coming
and everyone's offering in below market
value
and now his mortgage is bigger than the
value of his house so he's in negative
equity he can't sell his house he's
losing 200 quid a month and you come
along and save him and you say hey I'll
buy the house off you I'll take it off
your hands but I'll buy it in seven
years time but don't worry right now
I'll take over your mortgage payments
he's super happy your pain is mortgage
of 1200 pound a month his rent's owning
your ground but then you get a letter of
consent from his lender and you rent it
out a service accommodation as a holiday
let for 200 pounds a night and you're
now making a thousand pounds clean
profit or something you put down nothing
apart from a one pound option fee and
that one thousand pounds a month that
you're making you save it you save it
you save it and then seven years time
you use that to buy it if it's gone up
in value of course which I think you
will have because seven years is a long
time so man there's loads of stuff you
can do rent to rent
controlling property without even owning
it
get out of your job right now if you're
on a job let's make paying you two three
grand a month it's never been easier to
be a property entrepreneur and get out
your job it's never been easier so
that's my thoughts I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you want to come down to
some of my training you want to meet me
meet the team I'll leave a link in the
in the description one pound one pound
guys spend a day with me let's find
deals and stew business I'll see you
soon God bless